now the dangerous consequences of
left-wing crime policies are on full
display tonight as an apple store in
santa rosa california was ransacked on
wednesday according to authorities four
suspects stole over 20 thousand dollars
worth of merchandise in broad daylight
in just the last string of smash and
grab lootings across the golden state
and by the way our local fox station in
san francisco reports that black friday
shoppers hardly turned out in the bay
area today
is the crime surge scaring off holiday
shoppers well of course this is all the
natural consequence of the left's
normalization of crime and property
damage but don't take my word for it
just look at these outrageous remarks
from unhinged hollywood actor seth rogen
down playing car burglaries he tweeted
in a response to a post about a break in
quote dude i've lived here for over 20
years you're nuts ha ha it's lovely here
don't leave anything valuable in it
being the car it's called living in a
big city
right yeah i'm a native los angelino and
that's that's just garbage now he's
shrugging off crime shrugging off the
real world harm of property crime and
invasion and violation here for reaction
former acting director of national
intelligence rick grinnell along with
former trump campaign communications
director aaron perrini uh rick let me
start with you because you're also a
southern californian as as i am as well
and what we're looking at i mean there's
going to be crime in life we know that
but this becomes almost like i would
argue a stockholm syndrome dynamic where
things are so awful you have to pretend
it's okay and that it's normal is that
what you think is happening here for
some of these people
well look tammy you know because you
used to live here you know about 10 or
12 years ago
we started pushing this really nice
thing called sanctuary cities and
sanctuary states it sounds so nice but
really it was the beginning of the
democrats uh
attack
on the rule of law
because what a sanctuary city in a
sanctuary state which is really
california now a sanctuary state it
means that politicians tell law
enforcement officials to not enforce
certain laws that they don't like and it
started with immigration but it's now to
the point where we've got district
attorneys all over california who are
telling uh the police let certain
situations go and that of course
is empowering so many other criminals i
mean look matt and i both in our first a
couple of months in los angeles had both
of our cars stolen in los angeles and
the police when we reported it didn't
even come they didn't even want to come
they just said well this happens all the
time and so the people move on and this
is the result of left-wing politicians
in california trying to make nice with
sanctuary cities and sanctuary states
that's a great point right these small
steps and then it just kind of moves on
from there aaron
we've also got things like regulations
in northern california i think it was a
like prop 47 or something that literally
does what rick is saying that if you
steal below 950
it's just a ticket in other words
encouraging saying this is normal this
is what you should be able to do and
sometimes the argument that this was
reparations of course that's racist in
and of itself the suggestion that people
of color are going to be engaging in
this and should be and it's california
and new york really are the petri dishes
for the left that send messages
everywhere else do you see it that way
as well
oh that's absolutely correct on
proposition 47 you're right tammy they
reduced the charge on shoplifting but
increased the ability to charge for
felony shoplifting so they made it
harder to make it a crime in california
to shoplift and you're seeing that
across the country it's unbelievable
they called that the safe neighborhoods
and schools act it's astonishing that
they would have the gall to do that when
you're seeing this three of the top ten
cities for retail theft in the united
states are in california you just heard
the former police commissioner in
philadelphia come out and say that what
you're seeing in california will
continue across the united states and
why is that it is because there is a
concerted effort by the left wing in the
united states to elect progressive
prosecutors and district attorneys that
will turn a blind eye to criminal
behavior but there's good news in this
right what what are we seeing the
american people are pushing back in
seattle of all places deep blue seattle
we saw in november of this year where
law and order won on the ballot and the
republican is going to be the city
attorney and the top prosecutor in
seattle because law and order safety and
security matters so democrats if they
want to continue to try and pursue
policies that lessen the pellet
penalties and make it harder for
prosecutors to make communities safer by
charging for felonies on things you
better believe the american people will
push back and vote for republicans who
stand for law and order you know i don't
rick i don't know
if the american people and certain
voters in california didn't take certain
people seriously uh like the d.a in los
angeles he campaigned on this people
campaign on these things maybe they just
think well you know they say things
during the campaign that's so crazy
it'll never happen that this this is not
normal and we can expect that but
clearly it seems like in new york a lot
of republicans got elected uh things
changed a bit in california is that
going to be enough when it comes to
what what we can do to make a change
here or does does there have to be a
larger movement afoot
well we do have a larger movement afoot
it's going to take a couple of years but
remember my organization fixed
california found 1.4 million
conservatives in california unregistered
to vote
wow because we're so we've been so
apathetic over the last 10 years tammy
you know this you know so many
conservatives or republicans in
california who just aren't willing to
fight we've become an atm for the rest
of the country when they're raising
funds for their race in ohio or
pennsylvania they come through they take
the money and they leave we've got to
change here in california our donors and
our activists have got to get involved
that's why i've been pushing this fix
california you can go to
fixcalifornia.com sign up and help us we
think that we can take four or five
years and turn this state around but
that means everybody's got to pull in
the right way right and i think your
timing is right aaron we've got you know
look what happened in 11 months the
shift from the attitude of the american
people
seeing what has occurred here you've got
about 20 seconds here don't you think
that this is now
unstoppable this movement
i certainly hope that electing strong
law and order prosecutors politicians
mayors governors continues throughout
the country i'm hoping that in a state
like new york where you saw bail reform
that we will be able to see legislators
get elected to be able to reverse the
damage that has done for prosecutors and
district attorneys in the state the
republicans need to stand together those
who believe in safety security law and
order and make a grassroots effort known
to get these strong prosecutors elected
in states like new york california and
across the country here's how you keep
neighborhoods there's one example rick
you have it for us i want a picture to
go up about the nature of the american
generation that is still with us your
grandfather
the people the heroes the greatest
generation literally of world war ii but
it can be our generation as well can't
it rick
well i hope that we have young people
that won't just storm the beaches of the
storefronts of macy's in nordstrom but
that they realize that sacrifice for
your country is still in fashion and we
have to thank people like merle leishi
who gave so much for this country and
still thinks this country is the
greatest place in the world that is good
to know 97 years old he understands and
he's the
father for all of us rick thank you so
much erin thanks for being with me happy
thanksgiving weekend